Americans saw something new this month
when it took 15 rounds of voting to let
Kevin McCarthy Speaker of the House but
our view of the political drama was also
new cameras operated by C-SPAN were allowed
far wider access than usual now some want
to make that The New Normal Congressional
correspondent Scott McFarland has the story
one late Friday night in America the floor of the
U.S House of Representatives saw more action and
drama than Netflix plot twists arm twists and
a different type of political restraint the
15-round battle over who'd be speaker of the U.S
house unfolded during one of the rare moments in
which extra cameras are allowed inside the U.S
House chamber that's putting Americans in the
room that's showing them just what happened not
doing so would be hiding what happened every two
years the cable public affairs service C-SPAN
receives permission to record house proceedings
on the opening day of Congress before a speaker is
voted in this time that Windows spanned not just
a few hours but four dramatic photogenic days
that was remarkable watching that exchange on
the floor you never would have seen that from the
standard government operated fee with the speaker
finally chosen the house is reverted back to its
government-operated feed allowing only a few fixed
distant cameras controlled by government staff
here's what this dramatic moment would have looked
like had it occurred without c-span's cameras
inside you think these cameras should permanently
be in the house chamber absolutely Wisconsin
Congressman Mark pocan and some colleagues from
both parties are urging leaders to permanently
give America the better view some of us uh
midwesterners kind of shunned the cameras quite
honestly we don't like gravitate towards them we
drink water and eat Air instead for survival but
it's important for people to see what is happening
C-SPAN says it's made that request before for more
than 40 years and been rebuffed every time what's
the resistance why didn't this happen years ago
you would have to ask every speaker going back
to Tip O'Neill sometimes they don't answer at all
correct his spokesman tell CBS News house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy is seeking to make the house
chamber more transparent some of his colleagues
in C-SPAN now hope all that theater worthy of
an Oscar will convince him to allow more lights
more cameras and a better view of the action for
CBS Saturday morning Scott McFarland the capital